[Music]
ravi krishna reddy is campaigning hard
for boats in southern bangalore the
independent candidate is running in
state elections on just one issue
cleaning up politics it's a message his
supporters have been relentlessly
pushing out in the streets for months
connecting with waters during a campaign
stop reddy is a software engineer turned
social activist he's known for fighting
against corruption in government offices
the centerpiece of his bid is the one
boat one north scheme which urges
average people to fund his campaign
Reddy says it'll raise accountability in
elections often tainted by allegations
of bribery and photo manipulation India
is in misery right now because of bad
politics bad electoral malpractice spend
money come to power make more money that
is the motto as of now so what we are
telling people citizens now keep your
powers and rights your with you don't
give up don't give that to these rogues
and thugs who are going to represent you
but his campaign is in stark contrast to
the widespread practice of vote by in
Indian elections
reports say authorities in Karnataka
have already seized huge amounts of cash
alcohol saris even pressure cookers aim
to sway voters to support certain
candidates most of the handouts are
doled out in low-income neighborhoods
this woman said a major political party
came with clothing in hand are they porn
the party's representatives came and
gave saris for all the women they were
distributed by a local leader we all
know very well election times they'll
come canvass they'll pay some amount of
money to the peoples for the meetings
and the canvassing purpose it's an issue
that election officials are all too
familiar with Sanjeev Kumar is in charge
of guaranteeing free and fair elections
in Karnataka and raising awareness that
offering money for votes is illegal he
says his officials have
ready confiscated more than 460 million
rupees or nearly six million euros in
cash meant to bribe boaters that's four
times more than in the previous election
I'd present throughout the state we have
got more than 2500 various types of
enforcement flying squads and check
posts who are checking all types of
movement of people and goods your
election officials are working closely
with the police looking for any
suspicious goods that could be used to
lay off voters it's a waiting game and
they finally seem to have found
something a sack full of saris no one
here is authorized to speak on camera
but officials say there are no bills for
the saris that's what raised the alarm
here back at ruble Krishna Reddy's
campaign the anti-corruption Crusader
and his supporters are well aware they
face huge challenges in reaching their
goals but they remain hopeful if people
reject money politics cash politics and
the dynastic politics definitely we are
going to win retty faces an uphill
battle however old habits die hard
especially in neighborhoods where
election season freebies seem more like
a way of life